my my view when I look at this stuff is
I I maybe it's just me I personally
cannot relate to the to the desire holy
to sign a deal with another company and
have them take everything over
to be fair I completely you know
understand the thought of like man
imagine if you could make some out of
money and then you didn't have to think
about any of the business and stuff and
you can just do your show and then mind
your own business but I've been down
that you know that rabbit hole I know
where that goes well it's it's that but
it's also the success and the resources
that you now have at your disposal that
so few creators have you know especially
if you're starting out early on you're
trying to make ends meet so if you have
a network that comes to you and they say
I see Talent here I'm going to guarantee
you a living wage as Bernie Sanders
might say
um they're going to jump at it you know
what's really funny is that seeing this
story from Crowder this is the identical
story to the record label stories